what if every government had its own
cryptocurrency
well it's happening except they aren't
really cryptocurrencies they are
actually
cbdc's central bank digital currencies
they're basically just digital versions
of what we have now
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin are known
for two main things
being decentralized and permissionless
permissionless means everybody has
access to the network
you don't have to get permission from a
central bank or some kind of authority
it means all the data on the network is
available for
everyone and it's decentralized which
means it's run by the people and
for the people there isn't one single
authority that's in charge
nobody is able to freeze or seize your
funds now cbdc's they won't be
decentralized or permissionless
they will be run by central banks and
only those in charge will have
access to the entire network the
problems that bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies set out to fix
will not be resolved with cbdc since
they are simply a digital version of
what we have now
cbdc's are not cryptocurrencies